so i'm assuming that's something that's
happened to you before being a
millionaire who's african-american he's
probably driving some of the nicest cars
oh yeah
yeah that's like pulled over but it's
like a it's like a dickhard moment
though when you do it like
you pulling me over and you want this
car to be stolen so bad but it's not
it's so clean yeah it's so clean you
want this firearm to be off you won't
you just want so much to be going wrong
right now but nothing's wrong
it's so fair and square i just like i
love that moment of looking at the cops
like what's up bro you know oh you eat
much yeah that's me bro
that's me yeah i played with bro all
that same dumb [ __ ] but you pulled me
over for some [ __ ] skate yeah yeah
let me out i gotta go i i really need to
leave sir i do
sir can i have my id back my father's an
insurance agent i know my [ __ ] together
give me my [ __ ] back clock lee cause you
ain't pulling me over for nothing but
it's like playing on that
i've been
slammed on the hood of cars
i've been
patted down for no reason i've had to
deal with all the same similar things as
everybody else being an african-american
man
that stands over six feet right i'm
automatically a threat right if you're a
cop that's not
way bigger than me i i would see myself
as a threat too you know what i'm saying
i'm not saying it's like
it's a bad thing but it's like i've had
to deal with that
so for me
in life
i don't take things as all this is
unfair i'm sad
everything to me is competition so it's
like okay this is a game this is now
monopoly
i win
that's what this album is it's like bro
y'all gave me [ __ ]
i was aboard a kid y'all didn't really
like the suburb kids said i was broke
the city kids said i was a suburb kid
and i was soft
you know what i'm saying y'all said
nobody go to leave from oak park like
i'm like far as i'm concerned i won this
game monopoly like that's how i feel as
far as i'm concerned i won
officer
you know what i'm saying like officer
you just got to get better at the game
of monopoly bro but i didn't tell you to
be an officer you know what i'm saying
you could drive this same car if you
work really hard and put that [ __ ] in
the hoop
you know what if you put it in the who i
swear to god you could be here too you
could do this too bro you're probably
five eight and two hundred ninety nine
ain't got nothing to do with me because
there's some people that's five that's
your parents yeah they got nothing to do
with that not many people that are
fighting that's a couple guys
it's a couple guys man